نبدا اخر التطورات الميدانيه في حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا فقط قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
ان من سمتهم الارهابيين الروسي شنه هجوما
مخططا له علم منشات البنيه التحتيه
والطاقه واضافت الرئاسه ان الهجمات
الروسيه تركزت في شمالي البلاد واستهدفت
مدن ومناطق اخرى بينها اوديسه
وضع البنيه التحتيه هناك بالحرج واخذ وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني ان روسيا اطلقت اليوم
اكثر من 70 صاروخا استهدفت البدلينا
والبنيه التحتيه في البلاد وقال متحدث
باسم سلاح الجو الاوكراني ان روسيا اطلقت
حوالين 100 صاروخا في انحاء مختلفه من جهه
قال عمده اكثر من نصف سكان العاصمه اصبحوا
بلا كهرباء واضاف ان شخص قتل جراء القصف
الصاروخي الروسي على حي حيسك في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه بدوره قال عمده خارقين في
المقصف الروسيا استهدف منشاه هامه للغايه
ما ادى الى
انقطاعدات الطاقه
حرج بعد القصف الروسي على بناء تحتيه
للطاقه وبدوره قال وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه ديمتر كوليبا ان صواريخ
الروسيه تقتل الناس وتدمر البنيه التحتيه
في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا وهذا ما يجب ان
تقوله روسيا في موضوع محادثات السلامه
تتوقف عن اقتراح قبول اوكرانيا بالاذارات
الروسيه مضيفا انه لا يمكن ايقافه هذا
الارهاب الا بقوه اسلحتنا ومبادئنا
مراسل الجزيره المعتز بالله حسن المعتز
بالله يعني حديث حديث عن اكثر من 100
صاروخ روسي ما هي التاثيرات
التي يمكن مشاهدتها
بالعيان يعني الوضع الوضع الطاقه
الكهربائيه يقول يقال بانه مجري ليس ذلك
بقياده القوات الجويه
قرانيه نحن هنا نرد في احد الاماكن التي
وقعت فيها صبايا احد الصواريخ التي اا تم-
وصفات لها كان هناك تصدي عده صواريخ
وانقاذ عده صواريخ فوقها العاصمه
هنا لولا دور الكاميرا ولولا ضوء السيارات
الاطفاء والشرطه خلفي لما كنا سنشاهد اي
شيء هناك ظلام
هناك هذه المنطقه طبعا هذا طبعا همم
في الايام الاخيره هناك بعض
في العاصمه فقط
صحفيين شبه حريقه ولكن هناك عدد من
الصواريخ التي استهدفت في ايه وعدد من
المدن الاخرى ليست بحث عن عاصمه اليمن
الناس
امورهم ووسط هذا الظلام
جمال في ظلام دامس لا يوجد لطاقه هنا في
هذه المناطق على همم على سبيل المثال هناك
من ربما ااه بعض المولدات الطاقه المحليه
ولكن كل هذه لا تكفي في منطقه العاصمه همم
ربما همم الوضع هو همم الخشيه الاكبر هي
من سقوط الصواريخ خصوصا وان العاصمه همم
شهدت عده هجمات في الفتره الاخيره اليوم
كان هناك ايضا جمال كما تذكر كلمه للرئيس
الاوكراني فيلوماسيلنسكي امام قمه ال 20
وتحدث عن انه همم واضح انه لا يوجد جدول
من الحديث عن مفاوضات ان لم تعد روسيا همم
كامل الاراضي الاوكرانيه همم التي همم
احتلتها كما يقول هذا الموقف الاوكراني
طبعا ياتي بالتزامن مع سقوط قذائف الان
على العاصمه كيف وعدد من المدن الاخرى
شكرا لك المعتز بالله حسن متحدث الينا من